Oh welcome to fat man I'm Batman Kevin
Spence hi I'm Marc Bernard welcome ma'am
we're here again once again as always at
the scum and villainy canteen on
Hollywood Boulevard Hollywood California
put your hands together to the folks at
home no you're not fictional this is the
I just left home to come over here and
have the weirdest exchanged my wife on
my desk this gentleman named Scott
Holden does a podcast I do we do Batman
I'm Batman he does that man on fat man
which is a podcast about me
hopefully someone would do a podcast
about him and it'll be like that box of
butter just gets smaller and smaller
aren't you so he sent me a book for I
guess it was my birthday last year that
was like how to be a secret agent and he
was like uh you know what do you get for
the guy who has everything
probably this you know and so it was
sitting on my desk my wife came in to
say something before I left those role
enjoying [ __ ] and she came in and talked
and then just before she leaves she sees
the book and it's been there forever and
it's like she either she just noticed it
or she'd never fade pays attention in
the office but she looks at and she goes
what's this and I was like oh it's a
secret dream that I've always kept from
you which is like a [ __ ] answer but
she was [ __ ] she came back with a
rapier wit she goes oh my god do you
mean you've had an unexpressed thought
in your life
dan would [ __ ] hurt but I was like
that's good of Steel of that line it's
[ __ ] out it was pretty [ __ ] heinous
in any event
[ __ ] her the mature chumps totally III
got very excited this week I saw a
trailer and maybe it's been out for a
minute but I didn't realize it but have
you seen and this is I'm an out myself
as a closet fan have you seen the
trailer for the equalizer - hell yeah I
never talked about on the show but now
that it has a sequel like it counts I
think it falls under our purview and
stuff because it's literally Batman
without the mask
it's like black man it is this black man
it is so if you've never seen the
equalizer and you were always like what
do you mean the old white guy in New
York and [ __ ] that was the old TV show
Antoine Fuqua made a remake or you know
a movie of the TV show years back and
there's a sequel coming out now but if
you've never seen the equalizer it is so
insanely [ __ ] satisfying it's a movie
that makes you smile from beginning to
end with how vicious a killer Denzel
Washington can be and his performance
like he looks like he's being directed
not this is not a criticism is very
positive he's being directed by the
great Antoine Fuqua to like give as
little as possible in the fight scene so
like where's everybody else is exerting
and ready to [ __ ] go he's count like
16 seconds and then he just quietly
[ __ ] dissembles a room disassembles
room it's breathtaking to watch it [ __ ]
but the whole final third act takes
place in a Home Depot and when it starts
you're like god I'm sure this is a
sequence and they'll get the [ __ ] out of
here but because you look at the running
time and you're like there's like an
hour left there's no way they holy [ __ ]
we're still in the Home Depot and it's
incredibly entertaining you're never
like I wish they'd leave you're like you
could get a lot [ __ ] done in a Home
Depot great [ __ ] movie but have you
seen the trailer I have I've seen the
trailer
oh my god that's the summer movie now
that I think I might be looking forward
to the most I'm like he's back
and this time he's gonna [ __ ] help
Melissa Leo cuz she was in the first one
as well they were buddies and he's done
two movies Denzel with muscle leo she
was in flight he must like dig her as an
actress this will be the third movies
done with her I think Denzel might be
the only actor in Hollywood who has so
much goodwill from an audience that you
will watch him do [ __ ] anything yeah
it doesn't matter if he's drunk
my wife senses so I know that's true
like what what do we need to see Denzel
do I don't know kill a bunch of people
ba Baracus Thailand a home depot
yeah I'll [ __ ] watch that [ __ ] he
does one gun take away move that I
remember when I watched it the first
time I just kept rewinding and then I
would go around the house showing people
look you know you find something you're
like oh this is currency I went to have
a kid's room I was like look at this and
like somebody points a gun right in his
face and it's the fastest I've watched
it so many times to see like did they
trim frames was it a special effect
it is the fastest disarming of a person
I've ever seen in a movie it's [ __ ]
wonderful and stuff and I remember when
I watched it took it down to a kid took
it to my wife and I was like what do you
think did they trim frames out and she's
like I don't even know what that means
they do like in born when you see him
[ __ ] hit a [ __ ] fast they
trim frames our cousin Matt Damon you
met him he can't hit that [ __ ] fast
so I had to explain it to her she was
like I don't know Kevin but like I
[ __ ] dig that movie it feels like a
comic book movie plays very well he
tells you to like Telegraph's what the
movies about early in the flick he's
reading I guess Don Quixote and the
hooker girls like what it what's that
about and he's like oh it's about a
knight who doesn't realize like he's big
ceeze night there's no Knights left and
that's the whole [ __ ] movie it is so
good so I look forward to the [ __ ]
trailer have you ever to the second one
have you ever noticed that I think he
got this thing surgically fixed but for
the first 25 years of his career his
left pinky was all kinds of [ __ ] up it
literally like it shoots out the side of
his hand like like like it's a kickstand
for his arm
and like they hide it most of the time
in movies but every now and again you
see this weird [ __ ] pinky just swerve
into frame like why does this pinky all
[ __ ] up and he would just kind of like
not favor that hand but if you look
closely you watch like that there there
it is he's a [ __ ] pinky pinky off is
their story there
I hope so where is it an actor's choice
you know where he's just like a normal
actor would do this Denzel does this
there's he [ __ ] acts like he breaks
leaves yeah all the time
I've never noticed I'm gonna look for
that now so you're saying going first
first 25 years yeah I think somewhere
around after man on fire he had it fixed
or something while I have enough money
to get my baby fixed son of a [ __ ]
two Oscars I can't get this thing things
it's like Scotty James Doohan from from
Star Trek yeah I was missing part of his
you gotta be with the character and real
real life James really Scotty do this he
got a blown off in the war are you
[ __ ] me
yeah that guy was in the real service he
was in World War two do you think he was
like well this is [ __ ] quaint what
are we gonna fight someone this week
aren't we the space army they're like
nying I had talked to some people and
[ __ ] get him to philosophical issues
he's like you guys weren't there man
short of that
Wow that's [ __ ] wild I didn't know
that so he was missing a piece of a
finger so what he could never be like
live long and prosper
he was never worried if he did was the
other hand that had the nine that would
make sense just like he was butchered
for alive you're like he does have two
hands
Wow let's [ __ ] interesting [ __ ]
alright what occurs in their fingers
what have you been doing you said you
had something to talk about well I mean
I just I've been I've been in the room
I've been working I had to write [ __ ]
down based on I really think yeah go
ahead busy I get it no it's not that
it's just [ __ ] you know I'm so stoned Oh
two more things talk about go I a New
Castle Rock trailer drop today did it
yeah for those who have not been paying
close attention mark is a writer on
Castle Rock so Castle Rock is the series
that naturally we probably would have
paid attention to anyway based on the
Stephen like the idea of like oh my god
a Stephen King miniseries or a series of
sorts but mark being involved in and of
course we're paying way closer attention
I did and look at this trailer I would
watch this show really yeah I praise
from one of the writers so we did it oh
[ __ ] this looks I don't remember being
this good when he wrote it
holy [ __ ] is what they do see is they
take a script and give it to what they
call a director and sometimes she gets
better sometimes it's yo Gosar's but uh
wow that's [ __ ] dope man how does it
feel to watch something that you've
written come to life like hip did you
watch the trailer and be like that's one
of my moments yeah really you had
it's it's adorable and weird and surreal
in the best way like I'm going to San
Diego next week for the keno there's a
convention in San Diego next week right
ha ha what is it a weed convention
carpet-cleaning what is it yeah it's an
haberdashers convention hats are uh
spats that's for bats and and they're
building a giant [ __ ] castle rock
town in San Diego Oh
what they call an activation and
activation yeah so there's a giant like
haunted castle rock house right across
from the Convention Center which is
[ __ ] weird that they built a house
for a show that I did across from a
convention center it makes perfect sense
to me let me ask you this do you think
you've got front-of-the-line privileges
no because the writer is king in
Hollywood I I know some people who have
yes but you can definitely buddy up with
them but you could totally [ __ ] throw
your [ __ ] star power around the
situation be like this wouldn't exist
without the power of my pen
and they'll be like quick let the writer
in yes before he calls his mommy and if
you pay attention to this show that's
possible entirely possible so yeah and
planning [ __ ] for that I got a couple
panels in them on down there I'm
moderating a couple panels down there
one of which is in ballroom 20 which is
the second biggest room in San Diego
what are you moderating a ballroom 20
say yet oh you can in the back alley
later on right everything is possible in
the back later on - that's it the
uninhibited version of fat man on back
uncut so Wow so it's a gig it's a gig so
yeah it's there's 4,000 people in that
room I see your name pop up like from
time to time where
Fatman on Batman mark barnard inand
stuff like that outside of being a
writer you vault and you know you've
been in the biz for a while writing
about the business stuff like that so
we've seen you do recent like Hollywood
Reporter pieces and whatnot but you're
something of a go-to guy now you know
it's it's amazing what the Black Panther
surge did for my profile
oh my god the Black Panther like
literally lifted all bow it lifted all
Brown boats very very very high in the
water you know every black journalist
was never as busy as they were last
February like what you need somebody
talk to you on NPR hello what hello CNN
how are you I know some [ __ ] about black
people's stuff I'm acquainted with the
culture yes
it's kinda sweet it's not so bad it's
not so bad but I've been I've been doing
this for a while I've been a journalist
for 25 years
you're no overnight sensation I am not
at all just right off the bus so so yeah
the accumulated the barnacle of my
resume is enough so that like hey we
need a thing for a guy for a thing and I
will get the fourth call usual take you
with our origins our secret origins go
have something to do with San Diego that
was the I've talked about many times
like Mark when Mark was it II W what was
the panel called icons or visionary
visionaries that's it I always take it
one level further I'm like I was an icon
right you're like you were a visionary
legends we got a pool and a pond pond be
good for you yes he put me on the
visionary panels with Judd Apatow who
was like [ __ ] killing it right about
then Zack Snyder who was right before
everyone wanted to kill him
unfortunately and stuff he was killing
it right then and then Frank Miller was
on the panel as well and Mark was like
why don't you be on the panel with him
so is there was a really nice Hall H big
[ __ ] chitchat and stuff like that
this sit and shoulders shoulder with
successful peers
so I always felt like touched by that
that mark put me on that [ __ ] panel
were you short a guest is that why no
you were the first person I call oh and
then the [ __ ] first person you
regretted when you were like I could
have got somebody better George Lucas
was like with Kevin he's like I'll do it
and you're like sorry we gave up that
slot yeah so this is it's I'm sandy a
going it as well I go down on Wednesday
as for the last two years I'll be there
with the good folks at the IMDB
interviewing people on the IMD boat the
barge the good branding yeah thank you
hashtag IMD poked it is they call the
yacht but it's a boat and jay-z wouldn't
rent if they bring people upstairs and I
get to interview people so I'm doing
that like all day on Thursday all day on
Friday Saturday we do a live show from
the boat so even if you're not a
comic-con you can watch it on IMDb live
streaming I got shows down there you
know I have shown one Thursday night
Thursday sold out fat man on Batman Jay
and Silent Bob get old is right after
that I think and then how it would
Babylon that's also sold out but if
you're looking for me you can see me in
San Diego Hall H I didn't do a panel in
Hall H last year but I'm doing one this
year so I think it's 6:30 or 7:00
o'clock or something we're gonna show
Holly weed the pilot that that's finally
getting out there into the world which I
guess I should talk about next we're
going to show that and then at the
second half of the panel Tom Cavanagh
and Grant Gustin from the flash made
this short film called Tom and grant
like in their spare time so we're gonna
show it on the panel and then talk to
them afterwards big good time so if
you're if you're in San Diego and
looking for some [ __ ] to do on Saturday
night that's what I'm doing what are you
doing
other than that Pam
I can't talk about that's on Friday you
go into the parties
some of them I've gotten to the point
where I'm too old to do the I mean like
for parties my mother [ __ ] catch up if
you can
no it's I'm gonna do like one and a
dinner and I go to sleep kind of early
because down there is I've been going
this will be my 18th year I think in San
Diego wow my brain still thinks that
it's like 28 years old
rage [ __ ] and my knees are like you
cannot do this anymore like my knees
turn to powder and my back fuses solid
and I'm just hobbling around trying to
get to another open bar I can't anymore
finally some like Russian dude with his
watermelon legs in a [ __ ] petty cab
to take me back to my hotel there's
always that moment where I'm like
somebody's driving a pedicab I got 20
bucks take me home question yeah are
they generally Russian yeah what an
interesting stereotype ice it sound like
it's 80% Russians like 20% surfers you
got a yes that's like I'm in the 20% bro
it was always like and it's half the
time it's like Svetlana who clearly used
to be unlike the the shotput program for
the Russian Olympic team these giant
[ __ ] legs and pixie haircut yeah we
called O'Dell now in order to build a
profile that means you have to have done
this more than once hell 18 years man
you take a lot of those pedicabs once a
year that's 18 do you shave it up all
year you like here it comes pedicab
moment by myself do you go by yourself
for this ride you're like I earned this
I'm a big boy I'm a good guy I earn one
petty cab ride for Khan easier to get a
ride but I like to be biked around
ferried by a city there is a movie
coming out the [ __ ] trailer i
retweeted today have you seen the
trailer for this Christopher Robin movie
I've tried to see it but my eyes get old
baby it is tough to see through all its
emotional pain raining on my face and I
can't make sense look I'll be honest we
all know it's hook but it's a better
version of hook with characters you
[ __ ] love like Winnie the Pooh and
[ __ ] like that and it's those voices and
oh my god it is fantastic every time I
watch it I'm like wow they're not
getting away with anything this is
definitely hook but I don't care it's a
cuddly hook oh my god it looks [ __ ]
so good it makes me cry so all the
billboard again today with my wife and
the tagline on the Billboard was sooner
or later your past catches up with you
or something like that was about was the
rim [ __ ] [ __ ] it really is because
children I think in this one spoilers
who dies but so I saw my wife was in the
car with me I was like that's a [ __ ]
fantastic tagline I was like I'm
definitely [ __ ] going she's like well
you could take your daughter and the two
you could sit there and cry your eyes
out no entry she goes why would i
willfully want to be sad Kevin
how's look I don't know man like I paid
good money for that [ __ ] like you know
I'm not it's not like I'm a cutter where
I'm like make me feel but like but like
going to see if I'm getting like seeing
that trailer I'm like I'll pay you a
thousand dollars to make me feel like a
child again that's sad
I totally oh my god I'm so [ __ ] on
board man yeah it looks it again it
looks pretty what it should be it pushes
all the right [ __ ] buttons
I saw the toy line but they're about to
release which look exactly like the toys
in the movie which I was like that's
insidious and I want them so so it's
working it's really working is it
working on you I don't want the toys but
I'm happily willing to just surrender
myself to emotion for 2 hours and 20
minutes of that movie is that what it is
it's what I get now I put up at the
trailer and most people on Twitter show
the good sense to be like [ __ ] yeah but
you know every once in a while some
[ __ ] Nazi pops in there to [ __ ] on
the parade and what did they say they
said oh great
Disney destroyed Star Wars now they're
destroying a a Milne person that created
in poo but I didn't see anything being
destroyed there like it seemed like to
honor all the characters they look like
the original renditions not even like
the Disney cartoon versions [ __ ] that
guy
[Applause]
[Music]
this is an [ __ ]
well reason that's where I've gotten on
the internet just [ __ ] that guy and that
guy - [ __ ] you this and this is the
other thing which I'm sure is probably
right there in the news and stuff but we
should do it right up front the the big
breaking news I guess it was last night
was that the next Star Wars movie the
next Star Wars saga movie the one that
JJ is making yes episode 9 is bringing
back Billy Dee Williams as Lando Parrish
that for me felt personally satisfying
on the level of like [ __ ] great like
don't leave him out like everyone should
return for the party and he's a big
character and like remember in the last
movie last Jedi there was a scene where
it was like oh [ __ ] there was rumors
that it was supposed to be Billy Dee
Williams as the guy in the casino or
whatever but it didn't happen so then
you were like oh is it never gonna
happen so to hear that it's happening is
a really [ __ ] cool thing I put up a
tweet where I was like please let it let
him repeat the line like we can say we
can still save Han remember - he's
[ __ ] joking I'm an empire he's like
god we could still save hot and I was
like please let him say that and [ __ ]
it involves time-travel or the force or
some such [ __ ] and then we wind up on
the bridge back at Starkiller base and
[ __ ] Chu he takes out kylo Ren from a
distance or something it turns out Lando
had the [ __ ] time-travel device
hidden in the [ __ ] Falcon all these
years or whatever the [ __ ] I don't know
I'm no writer they'll come up with it
but regardless huge [ __ ] news for
old-school Star Wars enthusiasts Hell
itself oh yeah and also like they're
just about out of old people to bring
back
they missed out on an Peru and uncle
Owen so hey who we got left [ __ ] how we
killed off that dude we killed off that
dude
that lady sadly is rest in peace and I
guess we got to call the blood guy he's
what we got left you guys he's the break
the glass plan right
it's an emergency it's I think it's
fantastic and also you know in a world
where we just saw the solo movie and
Donald Glover was being set up for like
and was a really wonderful land out
covers and you were like well I guess
maybe Lando is gonna be him going
forward you couldn't see a world where
they do a spin-off and stuff nice to see
that like they're like you know let's
bring back the guy that started it for
us did you ever see him on Dancing with
the Stars
no I saw him on comic book men but not
Dancing with the Stars on comic book men
we played a game of what I wasn't there
but the boys played a game of cards with
him for a Millennium Falcon model so
that was like taken from the movie and
at the end he did all the lines and
stuff was really cool that feels like he
had more dignity in that exchange on
reality TV
that's painting a picture because you
were on the YouTube and you watch him
Dancing with the Stars he's not so much
as dancing as like your drunk uncle at a
barbecue who can't kind of figure out
how it goes so he's just like I just
don't to fall down man I just I got a
one step back one step forth it was like
girls and like stormtrooper bikinis ish
it dancing and then like r2d2 and c3po
come out and do a little two-step are
you [ __ ] me it's ABC disney program
so they got all that ass [ __ ] he's like
doing a slow dance with Chewbacca and
you just watch that [ __ ]
try try and be like oh man it's a great
idea to see him back again I hope he
wears that muumuu he's and it's the
whole time he was dancing I'm sure he's
like they better put me in episode 9 and
of course the muumuu is like Lando blue
with a little like black thing so I
guess just stop don't I don't wanna come
on then it's like oh they're gonna give
him his dignity back then I mean it
you'd think I saw somebody online and
Twitter was like hey man that they
should give him it should end with him
[ __ ] going off and the Falcon cuz the
Falcon was his [ __ ] and I like that too
because I was cool what a good idea but
then somebody wrote under it like no man
the Falcon has to get past on the
generation that's who I like that as
well so obviously I should not be in
charge of Star Wars because it'll be a
pick-your-own themed adventure what
would you prefer
he gets the Falcon back or the Falcon
goes on - you know ray Finn I think he
gets the Falcon back and then gives it
to Ray oh I think it's I think it's his
- mr. dispensed with
or as I thought like or I at one point
suggested like since they don't have
Luke and they don't have I don't know
what they're gonna do about Leia the
like the favorite old character they
could kill was the Falcon like if they
destroyed it like at one point they
destroyed the enterprise and everyone
was a calling [ __ ] the enterprise is
dead then they put an A on it and
everything [ __ ] kept going they could
play that card and just destroy the
Millennium Falcon which is you know as
devastating for most of us is watching
one of your favorite characters die or
it gets passed on because unlike a human
character in the Star Wars world it will
never age the cocoon like it'll never
get older it'll never die the Falcon
they could put in a movie a hundred
years from now and it could still looked
like the Falcon and they'll still
probably pull somebody's emotional chord
about it you know somebody's great great
great grandchild it's like I remember my
grandfather showing me this [ __ ] or
something there's also the world in
which Lando
and the Falcons sacrifice themselves to
save ray good night everybody
it'll never get better than that
oh my god could you imagine just the
you're all clear kid now let's blow this
thing go home except they're not clear
and Lando takes the shot and allows
ready to do whatever it is she's going
to do I'm gonna be honest with you one
of the first thoughts I had when I read
that Billy Dee Williams was coming back
I was like I wonder if they'll bring
back Lobo the bald guy with the
headphones like could you know cuz was
he a robot was he a man he did he age
can they like kid is he still like look
the [ __ ] same I knew it once you got
Lando you got the other L you got low
bot so I'm curious see Fisher
I know it would be fantastic that would
be great fanservice right there bringing
back Lando though is fantastic
fanservice
in all these years what's wrong with
your head I've never figured that out
you're writing Lobot dialogue I'm
writing Lando dialogue poor low by
[ __ ] colt 45 he's meeting Lobot again
how you doing
it's awaiting your version they're
meeting up after years of my version he
was always with them yeah he's like his
Silent Bob and should [ __ ] mr. Roarke
a tattoo just hanging out on some island
somewhere entertaining people I'd watch
that sitcom if you don't man if there's
like a Lando and like on Favreau's
working on right now that's been Fantasy
Island okay I don't think I have any
more chit chat up front you ready to go
for the news let's do the news let's do
it man Marc Labor's to bring you hard
you guys the latest and greatest news
that he can find on the Internet give it
up for mark barnard he dug up some news
I get to pretend to be a journalist
again in this moment in this moment we
also talk about ant-man we both saw the
ant-man picture [ __ ] yeah yeah do you
want to go first or should I go first I
can go first okay it's it's it's lighter
than air like there's not a lot of heft
to this movie even though there's some
nice themes like I kind of like that the
entire movie was about fathers and
daughters it was about you know it was
about Hank Pym trying to get his mother
back for starter it's about it's about
[ __ ] Scott Lang trying to be a good
dad to his daughter it's about Bill
Foster being a good surrogate dad to Ava
like it's all about fathers and
daughters and trying to do right by them
as time goes on sorry man you could
write that one yes I noticed that as
well very like you could have titled the
movie the wasp and ant-man and it would
have made a little more sense it seemed
to be very thematically what you were
saying it's it's it wasn't as funny as I
wanted it to be though you know like
it's it's amiable for sure like it's
it's adorable we're having like a
rollicking good time but I expected more
laughs from Paul Rudd who's a funny
[ __ ] guy and also functionally
immortal as far as I can tell he has not
aged since clueless I I don't want to
know what the Dorian Gray like portrait
is in his attic because some horrible
[ __ ] is on that picture
I didn't eat children he just that's how
he stays so [ __ ] Johnson's I'm
continually astonished by Marvel's magic
de-aging computer oh that opening scene
yeah I was sitting there telling my wife
about she wouldn't go see it she was
like that's for you and the kid me and
the kid went and stuff so when I got
home I was like oh my god they did this
[ __ ] [ __ ] in the beginning again
weird like they D aged Michael Douglas
in the last movie this time they did it
for him and Michelle Pfeiffer and it
looked like Michelle Pfeiffer from like
[ __ ] Scarface and stuff and I was
like do you think like she loves that
seeing it or do you think like [ __ ]
don't show me that like
you know I don't have a supercomputer in
real life and she had to like always
look like that do you think you would
like to be de-aged or like I mean I know
she doesn't give a [ __ ] really but like
I don't know I mean it's given the
length of her career I can see what to
be interesting if it was like Jessica
Tandy you know gets on hundred four
years old and you like suddenly made me
23 marbles like we have so much money to
waste man we're gonna dig up Jessica
Tandy Dee Agers like 20 and [ __ ] like
that back from the dead but like I think
it only works for them because they have
so much footage of what they look like
when they were young yeah you know like
Robert Downey jr. in Civil War was
literally Robert Downey jr. from like
less than zero yeah you know Kurt
Russell was like the kid who wore
computer at the computer work tennis
shoes and and so getting to see grease -
Michelle Pfeiffer on screen oh yeah
that's true she was a cool rider but uh
but get like this it didn't never quite
hit home for me in part it was because
the villain like ghost was kind of cool
but didn't wire thematically into the
hero mm-hmm
you know in as much as like she could
give a [ __ ] about Scott Lang that was
not her mission she could care less
whatever Scott did yes you're right he's
kind of the hero of the movie nominally
she's all about wasp like the whole
quantum [ __ ] like that that's what
her vectors on it so it kind of
unbalances the movie for me because
she's never about at all what your
protagonist does she does he care at all
he is a bit of a ride along as the main
character yeah like everything all the
machinations the plot really don't
center hinge on him he's kind of along
for the ride or her helping hand yeah
he's a bit like like Jack Burton in Big
Trouble in Little China yeah Wow like a
Jack Burton is not the hero of that
movie Wang Qi is the one who's doing all
this [ __ ] and kung-fu and [ __ ]
and like saving China Jack Byrnes is
like hey
not back in an hour call a president
like it's not about him he does it does
not matter at all whether he lives or
dies whether or not the world is saved
and like Scott is a little bit that way
in this movie interesting I yeah I enjoy
it I think it's adorable and cute as a
bug as my grandmother used to say but
it's you know the stakes are very low
and I know some people like I'm glad
because the last [ __ ] thing I saw was
half the world [ __ ] turning into ash
but so you know the stakes are obviously
not as big as they were in infinity war
and stuff up until you know the
mid-credits scene but it was I liked it
it wasn't as funny as the first one
somebody was like this is the funniest
Marvel movie I you know I still think
that belongs to thor ragnarok that movie
still really [ __ ] funny this movie is
cute and there's definitely like on and
laugh-out-loud Michael Michael Payne
your moments but and Dave too small turn
our friend empty I like those guys are
great they're all everyone's knocking it
out the park but like it's not I'm sure
nobody's going because they're like [ __ ]
I want to laugh hard you know but I
imagine like there was a kid my audience
went crazy like when they did the
[ __ ] slide sequence and stuff like
that and I was like oh [ __ ] yeah that's
I would totally get that
if Marvel doesn't have at some point and
I can't imagine haven't done this yet
but to get Michael Pena to narrate the
story of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
before infinity war - that's that'd be
us like I wouldn't read directed yeah
just whatever that ten minutes I mean
you get every [ __ ] person to do the
the weird little Clutch Cargo mouth
thing yes I would watch the [ __ ] out
it's good call I'd be money well spent
money in a world where they're just
digging up Jessica Tandy yeah I I
enjoyed it it was but but the tree was
like I am Groot I'm grew to it and that
was a good story because milanese I
[ __ ] up by that lady with the black
eyes it's I would watch all of that
trying to get the job I'll get the
jittery if they give it to me I can talk
fast I did make me finishing the movie
though it did make me go oh when's the
next one like right away I was Twp I
mean I guess I feel that way after each
one but I was kind of like ah [ __ ] all
right when's the next one I want you
know I wanted a little more the infinity
war movie was a [ __ ] very satisfying
meal and of course the when's the next
one was more about like will you just
tell me what happened please so this was
just more about like I was good but like
I'm still hungry
what's the soup course but he is a
fantastic director Peyton Reed like the
the fight sequences the chase sequences
the [ __ ] big to small the car
sequence so many moments you've seen in
the trailer already but like including
like there's a moment in that one of the
trailers that's literally from the last
tag like and I've never seen that before
we're like here's an image from the
[ __ ] tag and they played it like a
throwaway image and the flick so I you
know it just it I just yeah I was
waiting for the next one so god that was
great like I wasn't disappointed I was
like [ __ ] you guys you ruined the magic
like I was just like it was totally fine
I'm ready for the next one it did okay
at the box office did it yeah I mean it
made 76 million which was enough for
number one which is 33% higher than the
first one grossed in its opening weekend
fine then I mean the budgets were lower
it's it's what we keep on saying
especially where we said about the Star
Wars movies like if you're gonna spend
300 million dollars on all of these they
all need to be massive but if you spend
60 million on one and you make 60
million opening weekend that's a home
run that's a win so this is clearly one
of those it's a bite-sized Marvel movie
it's not supposed to change the world
and it
after with the box-office like they are
perfectly happy with how it did as in my
I'm not sitting there going I demanded
more of [ __ ] ant-man in the wall it
did exactly what it needed to do but
yeah but I but I enjoyed it and anybody
out there is like that's not a ringing
endorsement
believe me I'll watch this movie five
more times over the course of the next
year I got very excited because I saw
they announced the [ __ ] release date
of infinity war and it's like soon it's
impending when when the end of July I
think it's like July 31st I'm gonna be
able to watch it on yeah like isn't that
[ __ ] crazy and it's going to be on
like digital at the end of July and then
[ __ ] blu-ray on the beginning of
August or whatever so it's it's coming
[ __ ] fast man like and it just felt
like we were just talking about I look
forward to poring over every [ __ ]
frame and I'm gonna jerk off to that
movie man am I in my office like look at
all our heroes so much ash they all died
or did they what do you think man like
does the quantum realm play a role and I
think it would have to the way they
talked about it so much like it's not
like they were laying quantum is in
front of everything I'd like some
quantum pizza yeah what uh how do you
think quantum realm would play out
what's the possibility like what is it
yes she's Captain Marvel she never gets
old she never does um is it like here's
here's the dumb pitch they turn back
time because you got your time stone yes
and share comes out yes if she could
find a way old school and the doctor
strains puts the entire universe into
the quantum realm so when he snaps his
fingers there's nothing there
Microverse well they don't they don't
call it the Microverse though originally
they wanted to I've written interview
with Peyton Reed where originally it was
called Microverse which to me I was like
doesn't that set it up for the [ __ ]
Micronauts and [ __ ] but they changed it
to the quantum resumes or the toys
license I don't think they own the
micronauts they had the comics but I
don't think the ex I had the license to
do it now I mean this whole I mean did
everybody see the MN and the laws we're
not going to spoil the thing yet but
there's the thing that happens in a
thing in a canister which clearly the
thing in the canister will have
something to do with what happens in the
larger version oh that son of that
quantum energy or whatever that they're
kept I was trying to say thing in a can
you succeeded I failed yeah I guess I
mean you know what made me excited
though sorry stepping back to a man on
the wasp when he said that my fizz so
stupid my favorite moment in the movie
is when Scott Lang says hello to Jenny's
like hi hello mrs. Van Dyne that made me
go I go my kid was there wha
and she was like why and I said you
don't understand like Janet Van Dyne the
wasp was one of the founding members of
the Avengers and [ __ ] for you know
Scott Lang to be meeting her that's it's
not quite like obi-wan Kenobi meet
Anakin Skywalker but it's it's a really
nice moment she's like that's sweet and
then I waited a minute and then I was
like but in the comics hank pym was
really abusive and terrible and [ __ ] she
goes why he's so nice in the movies I
was like no he hit Janet he goes he did
not
I was like yeah he's an [ __ ] in the
books hate to break her heart with the
backstory and [ __ ] like that but yeah
man [ __ ] it was good and I enjoyed
Michelle Pfeiffer I would have taken a
lot more of her yeah I loved you know
honestly though what like I I did the
anonymous the mourning think about it my
guy did engage in this movie a lot more
than I'm like yeah it was fun
the that he went by himself I thought
was really [ __ ] touching like that
ultimately it came down to Hank Pym had
to go get her by himself because he lost
her
to the quantum realm so it wasn't him
and his daughter it wasn't him at Hope
it was just him by him [ __ ] himself
like I really dug back when she saw when
she was kind of dressed like a forager
but ever like that and [ __ ] saw him
for the first time like that kind of
[ __ ] really did it for me so much so
that like I remember when they announced
hey it's gonna be Michelle Pfeiffer and
I was like alright Michelle Pfeiffer a
fantastic [ __ ] actress but like
shouldn't we have gotten you know again
the chick from Basic Instinct
Sharon Stone like cuz those two have
played a couple in a movie that be a
[ __ ] mind [ __ ] but when I saw Michelle
Pfeiffer I was like that's [ __ ]
perfection yeah like she was the
wonderful soulful performance she'd have
a lot of screen time but what she was
able to accomplish with it what they
gave her to do she knocked out the park
like a person I'm always a sucker for
the moment where the kid reunites with a
long-lost parent you know like it's in
wrinkle in time while not a fantastic
movie throughout there's an amazing
scene where storm Reid gets to reunite
with her dad played by Chris Pine and
you're like you know what whatever other
issues the movie has whatever other
stuff it doesn't get to the emotional
truth of what it's like to be a kid who
hasn't seen a parent and to suddenly get
reunited after years apart is [ __ ]
real yes so much so that I [ __ ] wept
watching the Christopher Robin trailer
this morning which is essentially the
same [ __ ] story all right what do we
do you remember we talked a while ago
about Warner Brothers is making like a
dozen Joker movies yes a Joker movie for
every American
make America Joker again they they
officially greenlit one oh they did the
joaquin phoenix
todd phillips thank god I've sitting
there going please not let oh please not
let oh I'm all fine for him to get his
own movie but like just let's let's
let's get a different Joker right away
yeah so uh so yeah Todd Philips is
directing and co-wrote the script is the
one that Martin Scorsese producing is
the out of it I think he's a he's not
mentioned anywhere in this in this press
release but it's an exploration of am
and is guarded by society but it's not
only a gritty character study but also a
broader cautionary tale that sounds fun
that's what I want my [ __ ]
entertainment a cautionary tale it
sounds like they're doing Killing Joke
now it could be it's an origin story
it's relatively low-budget fifty five
million dollar blood oh so smart so
smart what a great idea yeah I applaud
this they should make nine at that price
like that's so smart like don't [ __ ]
go crazy fifty five million bucks why
it's a [ __ ] dude and makeup like you
don't need all the money in the world
and [ __ ] that's smart decision that's
somebody looking at Logan and going like
we could probably get a taste of that we
got a character that's kind of like an
anime guitar will do it for cheap will
come I'm happy are they making it are my
guess is yeah cuz is this that dark DC
or whatever the [ __ ] they're called it's
a crime movie so I think they're going
hard I hope so they'll be fantastic so
yeah they don't have a release date but
they're starting production in September
so they theoretically could have it out
by the end of next year if they wanted
it fantastic alright so it's been
greenlit it's happening you can't stop
it and we don't want to that sounds kind
of interesting yeah if somebody told you
I don't know [ __ ] ten years ago
twenty years ago you're gonna have a
joker standalone movie you would never
sit there and be cautious you'd be like
oh my god are you [ __ ] what kind of
crazy wonderful future is this but you
know they didn't see Justice League so
the so I'm holding on to my childhood
anticipation of like oh my god a whole
movie just for the Joker I mean they got
to sprinkle in a little bit about
right probably by the end like the same
way I remember in [ __ ] Batman Begins
at the very end he's like and we got
this playing card and he's like I'll
look into it you know they got to do
something like that if you get that
signal in the sky oh [ __ ] they just won
all my money right there they didn't
even do it and they want all my money
they better listen to you I interest
Elba
were you effects in the Furious person
at all did you give no and I'm told by
people who enjoy the franchise that I'm
stupid for not being into it because
they say it's very much like a comic
book movie they're like it's comic book
movie nobody wears masks they all use
cars it's like doing ridiculous things
the fifth movie is basically the
Avengers before the Avengers really yeah
where it's like hey it's Dom Toretto and
hey it's the you know Paul Walker and
what we got to do we got to rob this
Bank in [ __ ] Brazil how are we gonna
do it these dozen people and it's
literally recruiting the team to do the
thing it's also super gay it is it is
the gayest superhero movie you've ever
seen oh really because those two guys
Paul Walker and then where's Paul
Walker's character name I want to say
Scott Speedman but I know that's not it
Brian yeah Brian whatever the [ __ ] so
it's it's Brian and Dom who are clearly
in love with each other they spent like
four movies just staring at each other
of a camshafts and pistons and [ __ ] like
shiny cars and like I love you man I
love you quarter-mile Tom I know let's
go and like this movie's just nothing
but them standing in front of beautiful
vistas staring off into the sunset going
one last job man one last job we're home
free
we've got these girls that we kind of
hang out with but you know was just you
and me right and meanwhile they're doing
[ __ ] in cars that's like we can't ever
die bullets never hit us we're
dispensing with the rules of physics
we're doing [ __ ] that you can't possibly
do it's the gayest superhero movie
we will ever see and I loved every
minute of it and so here's what happened
they then added the rock which also like
amps up the shiny muscle dude quotient
like a hundred percent but why did they
do that like that franchise didn't need
any help did it it kind of didn't really
but the rock makes everything baddest
look [ __ ] it well add the rock it leaves
just like 20% better than 100% it
already was but here's what happened
when they did that the rock has what's
called a work ethic
[Applause]
Vin Diesel does not seem to write and so
those two guys hate each other and
that's for real that is for real that
wasn't like a fake beef to give people a
known if we watched fast in the fate of
a furious in which they are technically
the two top bill actors they are never
in the frame together really never
there's literally like oh there's Dom
Toretto's foot no it isn't there's Vin
Diesel's head that's not really and just
they never ever share the screen and the
rock did this big Rolling Stone cover
story where he just talked about its I
care listen I like to when I come to set
I come to work you know I work out and
[ __ ] I crunch the iron Palace in the
morning I come to the set I do my [ __ ]
and I go home there's another dude on
the show who just wanted to hang out his
trailer a lot and wanted to do like
karaoke videos and [ __ ] and just never
really gave it what I think you as a
movie star need to give it and then he
was like yeah [ __ ] it it was there was
Vin Diesel basically do something I
don't care he's like maybe we'll get
along together but probably not
and so what Universal did was they said
you know what we're gonna do now one of
these guys is the biggest movie star in
the world the other one of these guys
has Vin Diesel we are going to spinoff
from Fast & Furious and do a Hobbs and
somebody else movie because that's the
guy we want to be a business with and so
they're not be Jason Statham and and the
rock are making their own little
offshoot from Fast and Furious they just
cast interest Elba to be the bad guy oh
nice
because yeah and hopefully they don't
barium and ridiculous makeup like the
Star Trek Moseley just be handsome and
shiny and British yeah
and and so what's gonna happen this
movie's gonna make a billion and a half
dollars and they will make four more of
these and they will slowly begin to pull
members of The Fast and the Furious
family into is like hey there's just
like a ludicrous little cousin come over
and play and how about you you'd sure
[ __ ] why not and then it'll be like
Vin Diesel by himself wondering what
happened too fast and or furious while
the [ __ ] rock is like look what I did
by being the rock wouldn't it just be
easier for Universal a bit like then
you're fired
yeah but this way is more delicious I
think for them it's a slow burn man
you'd be Groot that's cool
yeah I mean [ __ ] I guess you don't need
a you could do you could have the work
ethic that the rock said that he had
that a Vin Diesel had and still be the
voice of Groot you don't have to leave
your trailer you could be doing karaoke
videos and then stop and be like I am
Groot and then go back to do your
[ __ ] goodbye horses dance and [ __ ]
yeah so that was a long way of saying it
yourself but is going to star as a
villain in the fashion defend entertain
and give it up for Marx best the Furious
15 man
good the last piece of news before we
get to our very special magical guests
yes is a sad one that last week yes
Steve Ditko the great and mighty Steve
Ditko passed away yes for those unaware
Steve Ditko was a Comics legend in a
world where they would make a Mount
Rushmore for comic book creators Ditko
would be up there
most people know of course as the co
baby daddy of spider-man Stan Lee went
to Jack Kirby and said hey man I got an
idea spider-man draw that Jack Kirby
drew a big guy and Stan was like I
doesn't feel right I'm gonna try
somebody else and he went to Steve Ditko
and he said spider-man and Steve Ditko
drew him as a kid and Stan
loved that and that look of spider-man
is the look that like still lasts that
design is so [ __ ] perfect
it's emulated today even cinematically
the character has gotten closer and
closer to the Ditko version of the
character not only did Steve Ditko
co-create spider-man he created Doctor
Strange he for Marvel so there's two of
your Avengers cinematic heroes
characters that earned millions if not
billions of dollars at this point he
also for DC created The Creeper for
Charlton comics he created the question
who would later go on to DC Comics he
did the revamp of the Blue Beetle at
Charlton back in the day the Ted Kord
version I believe that everybody knows
Hawk and Dove at DC Comics those were
his Squirrel Girl a Squirrel Girl at
Marvel absolutely 91 I guess he'd left
Marvel back in the day went to DC after
a disagreement of sorts with Stan Lee
and he was never public about it he was
very private man kind of like the JD
Salinger of comics yeah kept to himself
didn't do interviews and stuff I had
tried at four different outlets to
scores need to go interview and he just
couldn't do it like he had no interest
whatsoever in being the public person he
just wanted to stay in his I think
Manhattan one-bedroom apartment and
comic books some of which people have
never seen he didn't even like when the
spider-man success was going on in the
the Tobey Maguire era and then the the
Andrew Garfield era and then now in the
Marvel Studios Tom Holland era he you
never heard from him there was no like
hey look here he is himself the guy he
just seemed very disconnected from the
whole thing when he went back to work
and Marvel is a story I read in 91 a
journalist had asked him like what does
it feel weird to be back here what
happened back in the day and he said
something along the lines of like well I
know what happened and Stan knows would
happen but he didn't even care to ask me
when I left so there's no point in
talking about it now very matter-of-fact
and what about his work and created
Squirrel Girl character that's
incredibly viable about to be on TV very
soon so he would just say he was a comic
book legend as an understatement in the
least think of how many imaginations
this man's work has captured I mean
never mind the dollars that is captured
and stuff get away from the business
aspect of it everybody at one point or
another in their life has fallen in love
with the webslinger he's a fantastic
character and the design has a big part
plays a big part in it the perfect
balance of blue and red and then the
[ __ ] webbings and stuff like that
that's a man who is so frightening Lee
[ __ ] good at what he did for a living
one just has to bow to a lifelong us but
dedicated to craft like some people kind
of could go to something move on other
things and [ __ ] this guy kept drawing
comics as Mark said probably up until
you know when he passed away he was a
big iron Rand fan so he would draw a lot
of iran-related comics
I guess later in his life he didn't do
any work for the big two right at a
certain point but you know and from all
I guess by all reports he lived by
himself and died by himself yeah he has
no known survivors he doesn't leave
behind any you never married
I guess it's it's weird in especially in
today's world in today's culture to find
somebody so intensely private you know
like so much of our lives is in public
so much of the way people like him
lead their lives out in the open on
Twitter and Instagram or whatever doing
interviews getting pressed all of the
[ __ ] that a person who creates a
character like Spider Man would do you
want to know part of it and it's you
rarely encounter a mystery anymore and I
feel like he's a mystery like and we'll
never know the totality of what his life
was like for the last 40 years we'll
never know what he thought about any of
this
and there's through something for a dude
who drew a comic called journey to
mystery there's something kind of
weirdly poetic about that oh my god
that's poetic to point out
yeah man Steve Ditko he may not have had
anyone to pass it on to but he had the
world and still does you know a lot of
people maybe just don't know his name
but think about how many lives that got
touched you'd be lucky I mean very few
people get to create or work on
something that that has that much
staying power it captures that many
imaginations let me do in spider-man
stories long after we're all [ __ ]
gone and stuff so his name will echo
through the halls of attorney man give
it up for the great Steve dick
all right so happier things yeah happier
things yes we we have a guest in the
house tonight this is a man responsible
for a bucket full of awesome most
recently most intently the Luke Cage
television series on Netflix for marvel
he a former journalist a screenwriter a
man about town Jo Coker come on down
[Applause]
there you go that is a fantastic shirt
man if you can't see Joe's shirt it's
it's Luke Cage but written in the Run
DMC font [ __ ] fantastic
well this is a show good sir thank you
no there's no way actually two of these
and actually stole this one off set so
that's your prerogative Rose must head
I'm gonna take this [ __ ] shirt sir
the reviews I've not had a chance to
dive into season two I know marques but
I was a massive fan of season one and
the reviews for season two have been
huge his report on it last week I
believe it was was glowing how does it
feel to do it was one thing to pull off
a miracle once right and then they're
like do it again how does it feel to
pull off a miracle twice well I mean it
feels good I mean although it's like
it's like being in a movie like he's
like yeah we didn't of course get a
kappa something like that so like I I
you know it's always precarious being a
black man in any movie but but you know
the thing is is for me it's just before
I was doing this I was a music
journalist like back in the 90s I used
to write for five magazine the source a
lot of places so the metaphor that I use
for the writers room was when we were
together I said let's try to make this
season like you know Paul's Boutique or
the low-end theory or death certificate
like you know the second album that kind
of raises the stakes gives you
everything that you loved about the
first but then really elevates you know
the entire enterprise and that was
really what we tried to do
I mean I like I can't be the judge of
whether or not we actually pulled it off
but I feel really good
we did Paul's Boutique is an excellent
pool man Wow that makes me very excited
to watch what I mean you Jay and I have
known each other for it feels like
almost a decade now we met we both
journalists we were we were in the
Skywalker Ranch yeah we got flown out to
cover separate he was working for
premier I think I got flown out for the
prepa sewed one DVD premiere when they
had those shits yeah and and so I think
we were we were the only black dudes in
Marin County
hey just the nod and then we just kind
of talked for a day but what is it and
and and we're definitely not the only
two journalists who've made the
transition from journalism to
screenwriting what do you think is it
about journalism that applies to
screenwriting what what makes that
transition somewhat easier than for some
others well I mean the thing is is that
you have to like particularly I have
written like record reviews and
everything else you have to have a very
quick sense of description or doing a
profile like like say if I was you know
going you know half of these magazine
profiles you you meet somebody in a
restaurant and yet it's up to keep
inventing 25 different ways to basically
have the same conversation to make it
interesting like you know the waters
glistening off the crystal
it's just basically like adjectives
moving [ __ ] around that I think the way
that it helps in terms of what I'm doing
now in terms of show running is you have
to get over your shyness to be able to
talk to actors and you know just keep
coming up with [ __ ] because you don't
know what's [ __ ] you doing so the same
way that you kind of like have to keep
asking questions is the same thing when
an actor says well what am I doing here
and you're like I don't know well listen
what you know as you said with
confidence projects what you think
they're supposed to be doing and then
just pray that it works
what describe for those that don't get
it and it's still something of a mystery
me the job of show running would it be a
head writer or is it bigger than that no
I mean it's kind of I didn't I never
really understood what Puff Daddy did
till I became a show
because it's you know you kind of I mean
for me everything's music so I think
there's kind of basically two different
types of showrunners either you're a
Quincy Jones type or you're Phil Spector
type you know Phil Spector of course
beyond being a murderer wasn't brilliant
[Laughter]
well you know well think he had a
problem with the law but it's very good
at his job but like as a producer was
very much the spin godly it's all about
me you do what I say the singer is only
like the implement of his genius that's
not me I'm more like the Quincy Jones
type which is different in that you
basically Quincy Jones produce Ray
Charles produce Michael Jackson produce
Frank Sinatra all differently and
basically built everything around that
you know the Stars so you basically
treat like in this case my Coulter's
your lead singer and so you basically
just try to make all the pieces fit and
you treat every single actor the same in
that way and so in that way it's just it
really bespoke but let the show honor
you know it's really a fancy way of
saying somebody that's involved in all
the decisions but I think the best
showrunners involve everybody in their
decisions I mean ultimately like you
have the final say I'm obsessed with the
NFL Network and so like watching all
these like coaching shows and everything
else like basically what it is is the
showrunners the head coach and then when
it comes to the writers room I always
think of it as you know offenses
dialogue defense the structure so you
have people in your room that like
they're either really good at
structuring you know a story or have
really good zingers and you balance that
out like that and so you come up with
the scripts that your quarterback or
your actors really going to play out you
know Marvel in this case would be you
know the team owner and basically
Netflix you know runs the league and
this is what it is I mean you just
basically just hope that you could
manage the clock
I'm not a sports guy so all of that was
lost on what is instead of football it's
hockey Oh what is that so in the room
then it was part of the job that you're
like okay you write episode 1 you write
3 you write did you pass our writers
room we have a sign outside of it I like
I I named it the the Danger Room because
the the the the thing was always the
coolest thing about the x-men is that
you never knew which combination of
powers was gonna help win so is the
Colossus picking up Wolverine for a
fastball special to slash you know the
Sentinel is it you know is night Carla
gonna BAM somebody somewhere else it's
kitty probably gonna faze somebody
through something like and you never
know you know you have all these
personalities clashing but then when it
comes down to telling the story
everybody combines in a different way to
get the job done and so that's this kind
of like what all of us did whether it
was you know myself you know I had a
Kroll Kayla Cooper you know Ian Stokes
Matt Owens Matt Lopes Nicole Monta
Matthews you know in terms of the season
to staff you know all of us just
together just like just having fun I
mean the same thing with Steve with
season one as well I mean you know
because we had a lot of you know
crossover of course I'm gonna collecting
from season one you know Charles Murray
Ian's I'm sorry I'm Christian Taylor and
Jason poets but the thing is is that
because we had so much continuity for
both seasons I think there really helped
us but both seasons I mean just we
decided we just have a blast in the
writers room you know what were you
doing were you involved with oh no I'm
sorry I forgot Nathan Jackson
Oh God because maybe we met if I forget
Nate somewhere is just like crying the
were you involved with the defenders all
were you building your season to while
they were off doing defenders well I
mean you know the thing about the way
the Marvel television is set up without
giving away too many secrets is all the
rooms are pretty much adjacent so like
you know when when Marco and Laura and
at one point dub feature we're all
working on defenders I mean I always had
an open-door policy whose vice versa
like anytime anybody was working on
anything
you just come hang out and talk right so
you know there was you basically were
consulted but ultimately it's it's their
show it's it you know their decision
what did what did your pitch for Luke
Cage look like when you when you first
went into Marvel and like listen we're
gonna make the the defenders cycle of
shows and we're gonna do these four what
was your what was the take that sold
Marvel that you were the gotta run that
show what I said I said City of God and
belly is written by the staff of the
wire Wow Wow you know because that's
what the thing was was the belly element
of course is just the hip hop what I
originally called the what's hanging
vacation mommy universe City of God for
me is this like just one of those movies
that just in terms of structure in terms
of this culture and flavors it's put you
into a world and then the wire
ultimately is my favorite TV show just
in terms of just how many ways it just
finds different you know manners of
making you care about people that you
probably never would care about so
everybody has a story
and so in Luke Cage whether it's Luke
Cage himself or even you know a
secondary character like sugar who is my
kind of like one of the like the
bodyguards that we kind of give a story
in season two everybody manages to you
know be human you know and even a bit
but especially with our villain swebus
cottonmouth Diamondback or building
season - Mariah Dillard everybody Theo
Rossi who plays some shades I mean
there's so many different ways that the
villains are equally as interesting as
either Luke Cage or misty night what
were the conversation is like
incorporating iron fist - season two
because you know I have thoughts about
the first season of iron fist feelings
maybe but but for me it felt as if your
handling of of Danny ran
felt a bit like when Josh took over the
Hulk and like I cracked it like I know
how this character works now what was
your lever into figuring out how to like
recalibrate Danny Rand and Iron Fist
first season - well I mean the thing is
is that I mean I think we just were
collectively arrogant enough to think
that he was gonna be different on our
show of anywhere else
and so like that's just kind of what we
did we said okay like you know this
works in the comics we love this
character with our main character let's
just figure out a way to make them cool
you know just from the standpoint of
just you know what wisdom you know
because the thing is is that you really
if you deeply in the kung-fu
you know and in terms of like the the
movie mythos it's so much about like
philosophy so much about cool under
pressure and Luke agencies and - is
really angry so if you have somebody
that can focus and you know the whole
thing is he supposed to be able to
channel his Chi into his hand so if this
guy can do that then how what can he
bring to Luke Cage and by bringing it in
at a point in the season with Luke needs
at most they both bring out the best in
each other and then of course I mean you
know a way a kala Cooper just told it it
was a great script that she wrote but
also just you know it's not just having
moons hanging it's got to be the right
mood sang song so it's like that you
know the the fight sequence that we have
was this really just one of our
favorites it's just really all it's it
was fun that was the thing was just like
it you know just have them it just
inject a certain level of fun but then
at the same time make sure that there's
also the character moments and I did
love the fact that that Danny ran it's a
bit of a Luke Cage fanboy which you know
watching cuz for most of the episode
Danny ran is rolling with a sweet
Christmas hoodie which is my favorite
thing which I saw I stole one loss from
said too
the this is a character that people
wanted to see for a long time we were
talking about in the alley before the
show started I didn't know this did you
bring it up or do you bring it up oh
yeah I'm will the way at one point
Quentin Tarantino was gonna make it with
Laurence Fishburne SS little cage I
think this in the 90s well I mean I'm
just trying to imagine like deep-cover
Laurence Fishburne is what other
versions had there been and when when
like you come to a world where the like
alright well given you this character do
they say here's all the other [ __ ]
people have tried to read this and don't
do that or you just get to start from
scratch and never even think about
anything that's come before well I mean
when I was finally lucky enough to get
the job and go through all the different
interviews I remember the first thing
they did was they showed me Drew Goddard
scripts for daredevil the first two
episodes and also Melissa Rosenberg
first two scripts for Jessica Jones and
then I read all four and you know went
to a corner and cried because they were
just such just even before seeing the
episode just on the page they were
brilliant and you know you're thinking
like okay it's like daredevil has a
definitive villain that he's going
against in terms of kingpin you know
Jessica Jones's poorest is going against
killgrave Luke Cage is what cockroach
mister you know like mr. fish it's like
you're thinking that okay like these
characters because the thing about if
there's an if there's a weakness to Luke
Cage as a comic book is that the like
every episo-- is just a one-off villain
that he's fighting right but then all of
a sudden I realized that stepping back
from this is actually a strength because
it would allow us to kind of reinvent
the characters you know in the in the
ways that we wanted to you know for the
show but then at the same time you know
never lose the blaxploitation vibe or
you know and for me blaxploitation is a
negative because essentially all
blaxploitation is is a black character
getting to do the same thing that his
white counterparts got to do which is
shoot guns get the girl kick-ass look
good
so I mean shaft is essentially if you
look at the shaft poster it says you
know hotter than
cooler than bullet I mean this is kind
of the same thing I mean all you rich
around shooters just wanted to be Lee
Marvin you know I just have the same
shot and Steve McQueen and so it's
really just injecting that kind of
flavor into Luke Cage but you know
updating it in a way that made it feel
like a little more modern and then then
of course it's just the fun of being
able to reinvent cottonmouth or you know
even though people didn't like the
character I mean I really dig what we
did with Diamondback I think people's
without spoiling Luke a season one too
badly people didn't like the way we
switched off they didn't like side B of
the album you know and so but I think it
was unfair to Eric Lee Harvey because he
gave a really great performance and
stuff but I think people were so
emotionally angry about the way that we
switched characters that they kind of
took it out you know in terms of you
know what they feel about about the
second half of season one but I think in
retrospect looking back at it I still
think that there were a lot of good
moments in the back half of season as
well I enjoy and I like the fact that
it's it was shocking that all the sudden
it's like wait that's not the bad guy oh
[ __ ] yeah we're over here and also I'll
be honest with you it was worth it to
get to the suit in the end that suit
made sense but it's like I'm fighting a
guy who was impenetrable so I want a
suit and suddenly we're looking at a
suit that looked like it came right off
the cover of omoro comic like and you
found a way to make it make sense and
not be silly so I think he crushed with
that character I look forward to this
season based on what he was doing saying
him just basically based on what you've
been saying tonight as well but the one
thing I wanted to ask was when when you
get into the the Marvel Netflix world
say all the offices are kind of next to
one another so one could go in and be
like what do you guys do what are you
guys doing is there ever a moment where
you hit a wall based on what somebody
else is doing in another show or you can
write around that well the way Jeff lobe
described it is essentially like you
said imagine that it's basically like a
freeway and and you know you can go any
what you can drive in any lane but if
you hit a guardrail like you know
they'll let you know and so I think for
me it's like the biggest challenge at
first was the fact that the character of
Reva you know who was always
kind of like Luke's go to to certain
extent the way that she was using
Jessica Jones like we had to basically
reinvent the backstory of Lucasian we
couldn't follow like the classic you
know comic book version so that's it
wasn't necessarily a guardrail but it's
just like because of the fact that you
have characters that can exist what the
monster shows like you have to take a
different approach depending on which
creator comes first and what they do you
know the thing is is that I can't take
credit for forecasting my culture is
Luke Cage because Melissa Rosenberg did
and I'm really fortunate that she did
because I just think that my culture is
is such an incredible Luke Cage
you know but we will take credit for
casting small music you know she's
amazing as well the NAT we we know
musics a big part of it definitely I've
seen season 1 and the pieces I've seen
him season 2 as well and now we know
that music's big part of your background
when you i remember reading in the liner
notes of some john hughes album years
ago that he said music was never an
afterthought for him he goes i I know
the songs I'm going to include when I'm
writing the script being that you're so
finger on the pulse and so embedded in
music and you pull fantastic analogies
using music sounds like you're building
a season around
music and not vice-versa not like
alright we're done let's see what will
fit you know it's it's always starts to
the music and then I build backwards I
mean it's kinda like propyl rain it's
kind of like you know black like Prince
wrote the record first and then built
the story around and instead of vice
versa so it's just like but then you
always want to have those moments where
people feel as if they're part of like
watching a song evolve so like you know
in the beginning appropriating like he's
rejecting we need Lisa's tape you know
he's basically saying it's garbage but
then when he's alone he's listening to
it
and then he listens to his father's [ __ ]
and then by the end of the movie when
hear both become for the song you like
oh my god I've watched the evolution of
the song and so you just basically just
try to have enough moments where people
are kind of going along for the ride but
you always pretty much have songs in
mind and the other thing like happened
is like when you ask about that first
pitch when I first kind of got to jet
flow in those guys I was so nervous
about going into pitch that I didn't
know what they were gonna ask me I
didn't know if I had to have a full
season so I basically did a trick
we should do back in the day with music
like in terms of vibe is that you would
just take popular songs as cover lines
and also because I'm a huge Grey's
Anatomy fan like all those all those
episodes named after songs so I
basically was just looking through like
scrolling through my itunes and Gangstar
like all those titles are like moment of
truth take it personal you know be YS
like they're always these really great
titles and so I said okay let me just
pick 13 titles and so that if I get
nervous the very least I can throw
matically walk through what a season one
would be like and then that it's ended
up sticking so season one was all
Gangstar titles season two we built
around pea rock and sail smooth titles
so that there's always kind of like a
real like a musical component and so I
kind of look at it more like it like
assembling an album like I mean I like
the joke I'm making my season two is
that basically it's a bulletproof
version lemonade you know it's it's it's
really just like a concept record with
dialogue you know fantastic
so given as busy as showrunning must
keep you you seem to also find time to
you know write movies and [ __ ] last week
we went deep on the Creed to true
what how did you get that game well I'm
okay
so let's I mean if you can talk about it
well I'm a little elements of it I mean
essentially what happened was season one
of Luke Cage you know was about to come
out and then it came out did what it did
and then basically I was told like you
know we don't know when Netflix is gonna
order the show so it could be six to
nine months before its show gets
officially ordered so then of course you
know married father of three kids I got
scared so I just went and you know a
little was lucky enough off the heat of
the show to get you know three different
three different meetings got three
different jobs one of them was Creed -
which came up first and then literally
like I I signed you know on the dotted
line that in like the next day it's like
coming back in January so it was just
like well I rented pours so I wrote the
first draft of Creed two simultaneously
with the first
episode of season 2 and then you know
you write you know like they say thank
you the project kind of goes away for a
while and then when it wasn't
necessarily resurrected but when
Stallone officially came on to the movie
and read my drafts and you know at time
use them directed and then I got
involved I was in the middle of writing
the finale film and I was just exhausted
but then you get that call from Rocky
and like I literally like he called me
and then I heard the bell like you know
[Laughter]
I'm so tired but like okay I got I got
to get back into it you know I mean
ultimately of course as you know with
these movies there's there's always
different writers throughout the process
so who knows if I'm you know gonna be
able to share or even get final credit
but you know that's a whole WGA kind of
thing but you know the time that I was
working on the film was was incredible
and just innocently literally just be a
kid that dislike loved the Rocky movies
they even for the period of time that I
got to like right within that universe
was amazing and you know regardless of
whatever happens like I I'll never
forget that what it's a way you were you
wrote it before Stallone was officially
engage you involved well so basically
well you know without getting too deep
into the minutia will exit after it's
all like said and done like it would be
cool story to kind of come back and get
detailed story but you know he's always
like as a producer like hovering like it
was whether whether or not he was at he
was to come back and star and then in
this case he was gonna direct and then
he decided not to director but you know
basically the story was still like how
it's a story about legacy it's a story
about like when you're fighting against
a ghost because I mean the the ryan
coogler is creed like it's kind of like
brian song it's like it's like it's like
one of those movies that you know macho
men have permission to cry that Chris
Robin but you know is one of those
movies like you know where it just
affected me so emotionally you know just
in the theater with my kids
and having a relatively difficult
relationship with my father and then
when he gets to that moment when he says
like you know he said I you know I can't
do the rocket was like why are you doing
this kid he's like because I just wanna
you know show that wasn't mistake I'm
like you know brother son look hard all
of the theater lights and I was a thing
was like it was just so emotional so in
terms of getting the gig I was just like
you know I want to find out what else
happens to this character because you
know Ryan Coogler managed to make us you
know the fictional son of a secondary
character like the center of the
universe and so like what happens to
that guy with what else is easily going
to go up against like you know Fame like
like like what happens like and so that
that's kind of a challenge and really I
mean where the fun is ultimately when
you came on to it was well I mean it's
in the trailer was the kid Drago was it
always going to be that like when you
when you got there was that already in
play well I mean well that was the thing
it was like I mean Drago's the natural
choice because since Drago killed his
dad like and you thinking okay gee like
what could you do to kind of like you
know if he's gonna face his ultimate
challenge I mean that was kind of in the
air definitely it's I remember we were
talking about last week I was watching
the trailer and I was like yeah alright
I mean I guess I'll go it just seems
like more of the same and then as soon
as that guy turns around I'm like oh
[ __ ] they did it con duty like it was
just phenomenal
I can't wait to watch it well I think
we're gonna bring you back behind the
bar I'm gonna move into QA and then
everybody gets asked channel some
questions that's right man we're gonna
move to the Q&A bar give it up for chil
the interview
and now we jump into QA and Qi is gonna
join us for that this is the QA part of
the show ladies and gentlemen
we have one simple rule if you're gonna
ask a question it has to be a question
that well normally the rule is both me
and Mark can answer but now we got a
third so it's me mark and Cho as well so
that means this X my first time on the
bar like there's such a power behind
right it's crazy
nobody could see your dick that's what I
love about it here come in closer I'm
over on this side so you can see my dick
right here the question should be
something we could all talk about so it
creates or promotes some good
conversation and be careful please
and if you ask a question and we deem it
worthy you're gonna win some tickets man
our good friend Deacon as per usual as
dropped off tickets to the 40x theater
which is at LA live if you've not seen a
movie in 4dx what the [ __ ] is your
problem like obviously you haven't won
these tickets yet it's definitely worth
going to see a movie if it snows in the
movie snows in the movie theater man if
they're burning rubber with a motorcycle
you're smelling burnt rubber suits
wonderful what was the first movie that
you saw like that what did I see
Civil War oh man ok so it was fantastic
that's why I always used the example of
it snows of the theater because the
movie opens in the snow and I saw it
alone in the seat and [ __ ] and they were
selling me to like all you're not gonna
believe this and I was like come on man
I made tusks I'll believe anything so I
sat down in the seat and target all of a
sudden like this movie begins and it's
you know in the snowy terrain and [ __ ]
and then all of a sudden it starts
snowing in the theater and I was like
this is magical and so the seat moves if
you're watching a Star Wars movie and
they do the crawl your seat goes back as
if like you're looking at the crawl it's
so ingenious so we then 40x folks are
very kind they give us tickets to give
out we've got five sets of 40 X tickets
to a piece man I go to you if you ask
the first question or a great question
and the first question is going to good
old Nate man give it up for Nate
everybody
they take us there sir what can we do
for you I've never been in the spotlight
the first time I ever asked a question
was like the first show you did and it
was before you were like handed mics out
so I had to yell
first of all season 2 of Luke Cage pure
comic-book poetry I think thank you the
arc with him and his dad really spoke to
me because like I grew up with a dad he
didn't really like like who I was didn't
like who I grew up to be didn't like you
know what he saw and then seeing that
scene with him in the church like
basically apologizing to his kids saying
I'm sorry that I didn't like you I'm
sorry that I was wrong about you hearing
like hearing a dad say that and rechak
it Kathy the actor
rest in peace [ __ ] you did amazing work
that season but yeah just thank you for
that arc was just kind of really hit
with me and that whole season were just
balance and finding the peace of your
anger and your world is it was really
beautiful
no no thank you so much I mean you know
we were just lucky enough that Reggie
Kathy signed on because I mean you
wanted somebody that like was big enough
to you know if he was gonna say to like
the Luque sit down he's gonna sit down
at the same time it's like they just had
such chemistry and also I mean Reggie's
like the second he signed on I ended up
writing you know the the speech the
argument well first you know the kind of
the opening speech everybody's talking
about Luke Cage like he's Jesus but also
the moment um when they kind of had that
faceoff like I didn't realize how angry
I still was my father passed away in 97
because I wrote that scene about three
minutes in and in and the thing was now
being a parent it's like like like
that's why I was identifying lik with
like the zingers that your wife do at
you like be when people know you they
can be unfair yeah and so like there was
this this moment like when when Luke
says okay like okay you want you only to
forgive you then bring mama back from
the dead I'm just like that's something
that kid would say that just like this
cold you know so it was just what is
it's really just always just trying to
find moments of
Manatee like like one of the things I
say is like you know super gets asses in
the theater but human is what keeps the
asses in seats and so you just really
just want to always have that balance
well ultimately my question funny that I
bring up the first question I ever asked
because it was about Stephen King at
about reading those books and it took my
first year thanks to audible I've just
like been reading or listening to book
after book after book and you know you
read the books and then you watch the
movies that come after and were the
adaptations and you know some are good
some are alright some take huge
liberties some take you know no
liberties all and try and be exactly
like the book as people you all like
evolve as creators you've all made your
own properties and then you've also
played with other people's properties
when it comes to adaptations how do you
like how do you approach it like do you
say I'm gonna do something better than
what the original person had intended or
do you go as a fan I want to make sure
that what they wanted was reified here
so like what is the is there a mix or is
there sort of a a struggle for either
you know first it kind of depends it's
like like what I always try to do is try
to find the intention of the original
and see how much you can preserve it
really kind of depends on the medium
like for example I'm also like a huge
Harry Potter fan so I'm a Hufflepuff by
the way but you know the thing is is
that like it wasn't really until the
third movie that they that they kind of
clicked because it's like and this is no
dis to Chris Columbus for the first two
but it was so on the nose from the books
it was like why see the movies because I
have the books at home and it wasn't
really until the third movie went off
once the Quran came on where you know he
began to take some liberties that really
kind of gave it some bite but then it
was really true to the world but it kind
of like went in other places and yes a
lot of story was collapsed but the thing
you know I once worked with Walter
Mosley who said that look you can make
changes because the book will always be
the book if people don't like the movie
that
go back to the book but if you can
really strike a balance where you're
really hitting all the fan parts but
then at the same time you're kind of
like building something else I think
that's when fans feel like satisfied I
mean because you know even if you go
back to Peter you know to what Peter
Jackson did with Lord of the Rings I
mean I mean there's their entire
characters and thank God a lot of songs
left out but Tom Bombadil yeah but
because he got the Shire right everybody
just kind of just went with it and so
it's like you'll watch the movies
thinking like you know man I don't
really remember this from the books
because you don't miss a fish it was in
the simile all right for me I've not
done like a cinematic thing have I you
tried Fletch at one point I did try
Fletch and here's here's my super
Superman I did you're right I have done
things I forgot Fletch here's how I did
my Fletch adaptation I learned to write
dialogue by reading Gregory MacDonald he
wrote that series of books so when I was
doing Fletch one a wo n which is like a
book that was done way later in the
series but went back and told his origin
story so if you're a Fletch fan and a
comic book fan it was like oh my god
it's Fletch year one essentially so what
I did was had the entire book
transcribed and then I just started
breaking up with character names made it
look like a script because I loved the
book and I was like I can't bring
anything more to this so that was my
idea and then when I read it I was like
oh you know what you can move this
around and stuff there's a part of you
as a storyteller that just kicks in and
even if you have reverence for the
material you know like yeah but this
would make more sense like and I loved
that book but I always thought this
moment was weird what if this was
connected and stuff so you get to play a
little bit like that what about you
there's there's this amazing book that
William Goldman wrote called adventures
in the screen trade yeah and if you're
interested at all in film or
screenwriting like you should read it
because it's one of the like three or
four hollow texts in it
his idea towards adaptation is very
similar like I kind of stole it from him
which was he'll read a book that he's
adapting twice and then he will tell the
story from memory to somebody else oh
that's good and so naturally he will
tell what he thinks are the most
exciting best favorite parts of the book
it's good and that's how he structures
it it's what is making you excited about
the work to begin with what are you so
excited about that you're telling other
people about and that's the [ __ ] that
needs to be in there and you're doing
some surgery and making it all connect
but that version the the stuff that
claws into your brain is the best
version that you're going to tell as the
artist somebody will adapt it
differently but it's the that's the
version you were most interested in
writing which hopefully will be the
version the audience is most interested
in seeing so so was the idea to go back
to I'm did Chevy Chase so where are we
trying to do it for Ben Affleck at the
time I wrote it for Jason Lee oh I
thought was like oh my god that is young
Chevy Chase to me I thought he would
have been perfect then they didn't want
Jason Lee Miramax they wanted Ben
Affleck and then Affleck was offered it
for a lot of money but he was up for
this Disney movie instead and he went in
that direction so the whole thing kind
of didn't wind up happening but you know
I'm sure it'll sooner or later
somebody's gonna do a young flesh movie
and it was like kind of an honor to work
on it for a minute but I definitely
dropped the ball in as much as I was
holding on for one guy I thought I had
enough juice to get that guy a job I was
like I'm gonna hold out until they're
ready for Jason Lee and then I remember
when he got My Name Is Earl I was like
all right man Jason Lee has a TV show
now like come on he can be the lead in
Fletch and I was told that's a TV show
that was back in the days when like
[ __ ] movie people were moving people
and TV people were TV people and now and
I don't know any movie person that
wouldn't rather be a TV person like why
would you tell a story in 90 minutes to
two hours when you could take how many
episodes you guys have 12 13 13 oh my
god and they pull the taffy in those
episodes so much so that sometimes Marc
is like too many you know
but like the idea of like that much
[ __ ] time to play with a character
like you've probably gotten more time to
play with the characters in the Luke
Cage universe than most of the people
that worked on Luke Cage comics back in
the day I definitely definitely so
[ __ ] one of them that is a great
question give it up for Nate he wins
tickets Thank You JC who runs this year
establishment he is the be Arthur of
this cancer has picked another person
what's your name Khan sir my name is
Kyle Kyle I won't give it up for Kyle
okay thank you what do you got for us
sir
alright well it's good to be here you
know thank you for all this this is
awesome my question is uh not long ago
there's a story out in the movie verse
of Directors kind of shine away from big
you know blockbuster movies right like
because of fan reaction like Star Wars
and DC and stuff like that so right
because of the nerd rage you know yeah
you know we're all nerds here we're
prone to the nerd rage from time to time
so my question is for all you guys
what's a movie or a show or anything in
your life that kind of bubbled up that
nerd rage no that kind of lit that fire
in your ass and kind of pissed you off a
little bit I mean just anything they
earned I even bought pissed off but just
made you mad maybe a lot for me it was I
mean it didn't make me mad but like I
Lord of the Rings stuck in my craw so
much so that it wind up being a whole
scene in clerks to where it's just like
they're three movies about [ __ ]
walking and [ __ ] like that so that one
did I couldn't understand like generally
I give everything it's space for I'm
like [ __ ] hey if somebody likes it
great but I didn't campaign against
those movies but I was just like I don't
give a [ __ ] about these movies man if
they show me one more [ __ ] wide shot
of people walking [ __ ] you like
but uh but I you know they're
wonderfully made and he's a genius for
putting them together but yeah I was
they didn't call to me where you guys
rings people do you read the books
yeah books like you know I felt
definitely about the movies actually
like the movie so I mean I think for me
my nerd rages uh Batman Forever yeah
good call that's a tough one yeah mine I
think I'm trying to quantify what makes
me the most angry and it's it's always
like precipitous drop in quality and and
for me it was the Matrix Reloaded it was
the one with the dance party yeah 20
minutes of slow mode to head to them
like it happens weird a robot the first
movie is amazing and phenomenal oh we
fell in love with and the ideas are
there and it's strong and the action is
amazing and it's streamlined and it's
lean but it's got all of this [ __ ]
big thought happening all at once and
then you get to reload it and we all
showed up you're like what
there's two more these [ __ ] yes
strapped in I mean all right I guess you
could do that was reloaded the one with
the architect yeah it ends with the
architect there we go yeah oh my god I
remember watching that scene a couple of
times like when it finally came on video
cuz I remember seeing in the movie
theater and be like I'm too stupid to
understand this scene and then I watched
it home was able to break it down I
remember at the time like I was still
tight with Affleck and an Affleck was we
were talking about that scene I was like
I [ __ ] architects scene he goes that
is the most brilliant [ __ ] scene I've
seen the movie this year I said really
and it goes that dialogue is ingenious
you just can't understand its silent so
when the movie came out on video I gotta
[ __ ] every watching maybe I didn't
understand I'm stupid and I already
watched that if I can see in a bunch of
times and it's incredibly well-written
incredibly well acted but it's horseshit
like
if there is no great through-line
there's a lot of ergo to throw you off
the [ __ ] trail of logic but it isn't
[ __ ] fun seen to watch you sit there
going like wow this is smart and then
when you break it down you're like not
really those those those two movies do a
lot of answering questions nobody was
[ __ ] asking a midi-chlorian like a
[ __ ] hey George you know what I don't
need about magic is to tell me how the
magic works I just want the [ __ ]
magic and you know a child one day
you're gonna be working on Luke Cage
season 12
somebody's gonna be like you know how do
we explain his powers twelve seasons and
you're gonna be like let's just [ __ ]
do midi-chlorians bad let's just make a
magic blood it's it's all owned by
Disney's a goddamn Jedi that was mine it
was I have never been more deflated and
angry in a theater then than that maybe
Phantom Menace but at least five minutes
had been awesome like lightsaber battle
at the end of it you're like oh [ __ ] I
waited for that and that was great
nothing I waiting for
the problem I love Phantom Menace was
like you get this like probably one of
the best lightsaber battles of all time
yeah intercut with the space battle is
meaningless no way and guess what they
blow up ship again yeah oh and by the
way the Unicode with a land battle with
CG creatures that you don't care about
either sigh and they're all throwing
bubbles at each other this is a great
idea right guys I was just getting over
the pain of that movie you guys ripped
it right open again that was a great
question three answers man give it up
for a few ones of tickets well done the
pen thank you okay where we going next
JC oh you left him hanging
passing it on what's your name my friend
real quick cat ears movie posters
giveaway as well
oh Beautiful X let's talk about that
real quick what is is this it is this it
Jamie
cat as we all know we're on the show cat
ears you know cat ears what is this
explained give her a mic real quick such
as the explain this is that I'm
executive producing creature six it has
a lot of really wonderful actors in it
loudly lost if I haven't seen preacher
one through five there's a really great
tag line and I don't want to mess it up
so is it okay if I have absolutely feet
over go ahead
what's the tagline how you doing I'm
attorney Kyle Hester I have my
preacher's takes to produce it it's it's
it's an action-adventure and she was so
awesome to be able to to kind of make it
possible for us so basically it's a
taking out darkness six bolts at a time
and so we have I know Zach Galligan and
AM the gross men and a bunch of people
that you would know and it's just like
you know a dollar at time a t-shirt at a
time it's just like you were an
inspiration brother like making it she
thank you you know like you paved the
way man so I just want to say thank you
for that thing so I'm just trying to
blaze a path follow you like a night
where can they see it when can they see
a post-production right now so so we're
raising funds post-production about to
do another indiegogo for that and so so
we just got principal photography done
like two weeks ago
shot two weeks and so a lot of stuff to
do from here but it's going fantastic is
there a website you can direct them yeah
creature six calm you can see the
trailers also on YouTube just look up
reach or six and you see the trailers
that we have going on so yeah and for
those listening preacher number six make
your six bailed out spell it out that
will be bailed out previously right out
man Congrats when did you have when did
you guys finish shooting we've just
finished shooting on the 29th
like mechanize now yeah so now we're
rolling into radio roles here the
director he's gonna be getting into
editing and doing all that kind of stuff
and how his cat ears as an EP Jamie
sorry that's she's got a secret identity
Hattie Club yes fantastic she's like
such a champion and she's you know all
all passion for film and indie film and
you know you're all the rave and you
were an inspiration to her to help to
make you know this happened so thank you
yeah so thank you for being you
oh you guys thank you for saying that
all right preachersix everyone look it
up right now if you're listening at home
online and when you win some tickets we
can give you a preacher six poster well
done well done all right what's your
name sir my name is Dennis the Menace
the man is give it up for him ladies and
gentlemen damage sign so I got a
question for all three of you hope hope
it does not want him to sign it for me
[ __ ] go ahead sorry no problem hope it
doesn't get anybody in trouble but a lot
of us I'm sure had these moments before
where you either see something on TV you
hear somebody say something and you say
oh my god I'm the one who actually
thought of that
yeah so I would like to know from you
three what did you discuss with somebody
when you were in a drunk stupor and they
turned around turned it into something
big and you said oh [ __ ] that's my idea
it only happened to me once in my life
and that was when I was [ __ ] how old was
I when did hook come out 1989 91 anyone
so I'm 21 or do old they announced it
this was the year before so I'm 20 and
I'm still living at my parents house 21
Jackson Street and I had this amazing
[ __ ] dream where I was like they
should make an adult version of Peter
Pan where Peter Pan grows up what a
great idea imma start writing that
and then I got up in the morning to get
ready to go to work and my father was
watching Good Morning America and there
was a report on Steven Spielberg just
signed on to make a movie called hook
which is about Peter Pan growing up and
I was like what the [ __ ] is like oh my
god it's thoughtcrime he's stolen from
me and my father explained to me that
they had been talking about it all
morning and I probably it just seeped
into my subconscious from the TV and I
said to my father
[ __ ] you're on Spielberg's payroll
that's kind of [ __ ] you say to somebody
that had the original idea for hook but
other than that I don't think I've ever
had experience with that never I've been
lucky enough to never have that
experience okay I I was an intern on he
was between my junior and senior year of
college I was an intern on Star Trek
Deep Space nine he was the first time I
was ever in LA I was 20 years old I
think yeah about right I couldn't drink
yet but I spent this summer in Los
Angeles by myself and so part of being
an intern was you kind of just sat in on
[ __ ] you went to production meetings you
read scripts because at the time Star
Trek was the only television show on the
air and the last one to ever do this
that had opened submission policy
anybody from anywhere could write a Star
Trek script and send it into Paramount
and your script would get read are you
[ __ ] me
absolutely and Jane Espenson got her
start by selling a script there Ron
Moore got his start by selling the
script there it was it was like the
on-ramp for nerds who wanted to work in
TV Wow
back in the juice the episodes or is it
just like hey you're this writer come on
I mean they absolutely produced episodes
have we've lost the script you know
sometimes the only got story credit
sometimes they got that we're just gonna
[ __ ] do that one cuz we're making 30
of these a year and we need a couple of
scripts from from freelancer had they
known the future they would have been
like we should shoot a show about that
process
make it a contest but so I was an intern
and doing all that [ __ ] but but the
showrunner at the time of Deep Space
nine who was for the entire time got him
Irish Stephen Baer who who was also
twenty years after that my boss on
alphas and is now I think the number two
on Outlander but he invited me to
everything's I come sit on pitch
sessions come sit on a story brings come
like you're a [ __ ] intern do do
everything you can possibly do so they
were breaking like the fourth episode of
the first season of ds9 which was not a
good show
in this first season all Star Trek shows
suck in enthusiam and there was some
like they needed an obstacle for Cisco
and Kira to have to go through to gain
the trust of some alien race and I was
like what if they play like hopscotch
and I got locked out of there because
that's a dumb [ __ ] idea for a
science-fiction show where your lead
your first black captain is playing
hopscotch in a [ __ ] alien world so
I'm like yeah you're right I'm just the
[ __ ] intern eight months later I go
home and I'm just watching the show to
recognize this is a short work done and
I see that [ __ ] episode and there is
hawk from Spenser for hire playing
[ __ ] hopscotch on an alien planet it
was like and like didn't want to admit
that was my idea because it's a shitty
[Music]
[Applause]
that was the one time I had that oh [ __ ]
that was my thing and I didn't get paid
for it but it's okay Alamo rain was the
[ __ ] dumbass game it was you got one
yeah big one I was one of the lac salé
was the last rider before production to
work on Straight Outta Compton Oh for a
couple of days well and so a couple of
scenes that I wrote meet in the movie so
like one of them is the nothing but a G
thang scene and so every time I see that
seeing them like they have it that that
would have been one that would have been
cool disrespect but I mean that's the
thing it's like a meaning that you know
it's like success has many fathers
failures an orphan so you know this is
one of those things where I mean it's
like it's cool to kind of see something
that you're a part of it even is that a
little part that was a great question
got great answers you win tickets give
it up right all right JC take us to
another one to take us to somebody
either to session tickets left what's
your name young camper hi my name is
Austin so all three you are fantastic
writers thank so my question is how do
you guys get past writer's block
especially if you have a time crunch
it's still hard
it's feeder I mean you know every single
time like you know I the metaphor I
always use it's like that moment in
x-men when when rogue ass Wolverine like
like every time you pop your claws you
feelings as it hurts every time you know
like it's really the same thing it's
just like you know the way that I try to
do it is this like I just try to break
it up as much as I can and then when
people ask me about like you know like
I'm working two jobs I'm doing all this
stuff like how do you find time to write
screenplays the secret that I use is
that you just just write seven to ten
minutes a day you can find seven minutes
even if you find three-and-a-half
minutes in the morning three nap before
you go to sleep but if you commit to
those
ten minutes on a daily basis it's kind
of like doing push-ups or anything else
it's like an exercise for the brain but
cumulative Lee it'll build up I mean you
just I mean I think the thing is is that
you just can't it's gonna suck all
first-draft suck they do it it's do and
so you just have to just keep pushing
past the fact that you think it sucks to
just get to the end of it and you'll
learn more from from getting to the end
even if it sucks and rewriting or going
away and coming back to it then you will
by not doing it at all
because what you don't want to do is be
the person at the party that I miss one
first thing I learned in Hollywood is
like there's always this person at the
party that's like the life of the party
and they're talking about the screenplay
and then you run into them about a year
later there's still talk about the same
screenplay and then you run into them
again they're still talking about the
same screenplay you realize oh this is
their party trip because you know cuz
they're not home they're not writing
they're not really doing anything and
that's who you don't want to be so even
if it sucks just keep going I never go
past the first draft that's why all my
[ __ ] I just learned something today and
that's useful I I don't get blocked as
much as I will get lays sometimes where
I'm like I'd rather [ __ ] read the
Internet then like write or something
like that but I like writing and I don't
get blocked because ultimately it's a
useful tool to get out of anything any
other situation if you're ever feeling
[ __ ] depressed in life just start
writing you'll find a whole new kind of
depression to worry about as you like I
sucked don't but it being creative just
takes you into a different world and
like makes things better so I the best
advice I could have for if you've got a
block is I know some people start
something and then like just leave it
like get block I say push through and
finish it even if it's [ __ ] terrible
don't give it dominion over you you are
you are he you have dominion over it I
was recently on Joe Rogan podcast and he
said this really [ __ ] interesting
thing about Whitney Cummings
the comedian she's big fan of dogs I
didn't know that [ __ ] and she says that
when she walks into a room that like
she's got a bunch of dogs she comes home
she don't interact with the dogs I
come into a room like hey and I start
making up voices for him and she don't
like that they get all the attention she
gets home she goes about her day if
they're a bunch of him in front of her
she walks right through I'm not in a
shitty way like [ __ ] off but just to
just to show them like I I'm in charge
here like I am top dog I am alpha which
I guess you have to do for a pack
mentality I guess so I think that's how
you treat the the writing like I I will
finish this you don't control me I
control you I'm gonna finish this
[ __ ] story it may never become
anything but it's gonna be done you will
get finished and stuff and it's not
always that hostile sometimes like you
know you'd like Jo is saying you sit
down like the father seen just flowed
and stuff like that but not everything
could be the thing you've been waiting
your whole life to write and sometimes
you got to write the borinage chuffa
that just connect [ __ ] and in movies you
don't have to do that as much because
you want as much time so it's just like
everything's exciting in movies and
whatnot but I imagine when you got to
fill 13 episodes you're like the [ __ ]
does he say today I don't know like I
know he's strong let's start there I
guess but just get through it finish it
no matter what even if even if the lot
if it makes no [ __ ] sense or doesn't
fit together just finish it so you could
be like you're done and then you could
either improve upon it or be like this
is finished and now I'm gonna start
something else new and that thing won't
like haunt you how do I get through
writer's block bills yeah but also just
the idea that that I especially early on
I used to promise myself something if I
finished it oh my god I do that too
little treats you know like I'm getting
them [ __ ] massage because I wrote
today was always a video game there was
a game I wanted to play like Skyrim
would sit in the [ __ ] wrapper like
right above my computers half-finished
I can play that if I finish my first
draft and however long it took me to get
there that was the goal if I get to do
that I get to play but his Road done the
problem there became too many deadlines
and not enough time for the games I
actually wanted to play you have to
replace that and then when I quit my day
job it became literally bills like if
you don't write you don't get paid and
if you don't get paid people begin to go
hungry and then it gets ugly but it's
finding finding the the gold at the end
of the rainbow you know like everybody
has said it's not always fun it's not
always going to be great but at the end
of the day if you're right are you right
and if you're if you're feeling it it's
the only thing that you can do to make
it better you know there's there's no
problem that personally I feel that I
can't get out of I can write my way out
of any problem you know am I depressed
today I'll write something fun don't
have enough money I will write something
that gets me paid do I do I have a dream
that I want to come true I'm gonna put
it on the page like you can write
yourself out of any problem you have
it's a fun gig I mean whether or not
it's a gig right I mean it was more fun
if you get paid to do it but yeah it's
something that they tell me I have no
idea but it's something that that you
you know ultimately for me I always
remember like you wanted this like oh my
god your whole [ __ ] life you've been
telling people you're a writer even
before you were one before other people
acknowledge you as such like you wanted
this so never [ __ ] look a gift horse
in the mouth and and it's still like fun
like at the end of the day like this is
ridiculous and dope be easy analogy but
I can't think of many other ways in life
to play God without [ __ ] up a whole
human being in the process yeah like you
know when you have a child you could
always be like I'm gonna run their life
like a [ __ ] three-act movie and that
would ruin their [ __ ] life but like
when you've got like nothing at stake
there's no skin in the game nobody gonna
get hurt if you're like [ __ ]
then Deadpool dies you know but [ __ ]
he doesn't really because it's a movie
and [ __ ] spoilers so so you know you
could create your own little world and
said that should always be able to get
you motivated as well remember the fun
of it it's fun it should never feel like
painstaking work even when there are
moments where you're like at a deadline
or something like that
you got a rare gift if you can write at
all like [ __ ] my father would have
killed for that sort of thing like he
was a reader but he would have liked to
create stories and stuff like that so do
it you know in those moments where
you're like oh I [ __ ] can't break
through for everybody that it's like bro
I can't even get to a place where I have
writer's block because I could never
[ __ ] imagine writing something so
breakthrough for those cats that don't
have the gift that you have maybe I'm
not gonna fund writing sucks but not
writing sucks more you know and who
that's good what a brighter thing to say
that's fantastic but but it is one of
those things I mean it's just like you
just you just gotta keep going you know
I'm you know I don't want to get all I'm
just generous about it just keep
swimming but it is is this true you know
find your dory is what he's saying what
a great question you win Tiggers give it
up runway
[Applause]
jaesi bring us home we go one last hey
what's your name
autumn everyone first say I watched Luke
Cage season two I both love and hate you
right now and I won't give away the
season finale okay but that's why okay
I'll take it as was the plan but it was
a hate because I in love because I
really enjoyed the characters trajectory
especially looking at shades and looking
at Mariah and Tilda with her and and
Luke and how they all just kind of grew
and evolved in different ways but then I
also watched Whitney risk recently and
and not just hit me even more because it
just reminded me especially within
communities of color just sort of the
family secrets mhm and how those kind of
get exposed and how those are insidious
and kind of play out some mental health
I'm sorry Whitney documentary yeah so
they did a documentary Kevin McDonald I
think and they did a Whitney document
one that's coming out yeah now what cuz
they're not dating
there's a there's a revelation in terms
of Whitney's past yeah in terms of in
terms of some really ugly family pain
that ironically mirrors something that
happens in Mariah's past yeah and the
thing that it's without revealing the
twist is one of those things that you
know when I remember reading about Ivan
see the documentary yet like like we
would have said oh my god it's crazy how
you you do something fictional and then
you find out that it really happened in
that way just you know in a different
way but like that emotional truth and
just what it does to a person you know
it's crazy yeah that's my work is more
within mental health and sexuality
education so just seeing those two kind
of dynamics play out with Luke and
so in Luke Cage and Whitney but yeah
so love and hate you but my question for
all you guys is that especially since
music is so integral into Luke Cage and
I love draw and I love to dinner and I
was like Stephen Marley Oh like yes okay
curious like yes thank you
what would be for each you guys that
album that would tell your life and what
would be the song title oh wow oh my god
I wish we can give you 20 tickets okay
somebody more inventive and creative and
thoughtful than may begin
imma let the music German let's go first
yeah just so I get it right
what pick an album that that I think is
kind of like personifies like what I
feel like your whole life and then one
track is the title of the movie the
movie of my life does it have two should
it be from the same album nope oh my god
that's rather broad you're like this and
pick another thing altogether rather it
be because like when you had Pete and
all that kind of stuff and just how you
did like the reminisce not me on it yeah
I might have to go first because I'm
afraid che will also choose this one
yeah Stevie Wonder songs in the key of
life ooh that's good
oh wait what's the as is that the song
that would be the new movie yeah mark
barnard is as
check out my ass
what explain give a little texture for
this
I mean Stevie Wonder is [ __ ] Stevie
Wonder of course amazing yeah and and
songs in the key of life is wonderful
his [ __ ] magnum opus but there's
there's the [ __ ] bops in that album
and there's the bangers and then there's
the ballads and getting across that
sense of the the totality of a life in a
way and and as is my favorite song on
that album
because structurally it it operates like
waves crashing on the shore like it just
continues to like it churns
over and over and over again and the
voices in the song begin to change and
in adds new shades and new complexions
that life life is rhythmic that way life
finds you in routines it finds you in
cycles that continue to repeat
themselves and sometimes you need new
voices to help change what those cycles
are like so that's that's that's the
[ __ ] I just made up way to tread
water for me let's see I will sign of
the times
it's probably the princess sign of the
times popular by my favorite ally but
the song I would use would be another
Prince song joy and repetition because
that song in terms of house written in
and structurally like the story of the
song of him going to a club and seeing
this girl and running outside with her
and it's raining and and you know the
the repetition he's talking about is
actually her saying love me over and
over again and just the way that the
whole song is written like you you can
listen to song 20 times until you
finally kind of get the point of the
song and and that's what I love about
princes as an artist is that like he
always found different ways to
communicate things but and it's just
complex but it's simple at the same time
I don't know how that you know I guess
the joy and repetition is as a writer
you repeat yourself they have to find
different ways to reinvent yourself over
again but you repeat the cycle so I
think that that best would be how it
would kind of reflect my life to stir an
extent that's a question that's a
beautiful answer though
Wow [ __ ] that was good I you know let
me see believe it or not there is an emo
kid buried in me somewhere and the emo
kid in me is screaming out say [ __ ]
disintegration by the cure but like I'm
I'm on it like I'm a much happier person
than that so it can't be that so in
thinking while the boys were coming up
with theirs while listening to theirs
and being impressed and still trying to
[ __ ] think of mine at the same time I
might default to the first record I ever
bought with my own money there are
records that I got from like my brother
or sister or [ __ ] like of course my
parents bought me the story of Star Wars
and the soundtracks absolutely but the
first record that I bought with my own
money was stop making sense the Talking
Heads concert so it's a it's a you know
if you know the heads body of work it's
almost a greatest hits album it takes
from all their entire body of work so
it's a best-of kind of I would choose
that album and I think I would take
once-in-a-lifetime but it's a little on
the nose I like joy repetition much
better man there's so much so that as
you were saying that I was like I know
what I'm listening to oh I Drive home
did we get everybody everybody go that
was a fantastic question you definitely
want a good job well the toughest
questions ever yeah hands down
[ __ ] we're out of tickets means we're
out of questions and stuff like that
which means the show is almost at an end
I'm gonna throw out one plug for
tomorrow
Holly weed which is a show that a pilot
we shot two and a half [ __ ] years ago
this is only a story that I'm sharing
well hey because if you're remotely
interested in me you might be interested
in this but more importantly there's a
moral to the whole story two and a half
years ago we shot this [ __ ] pilot
with a company called Fremantle me and
Donnell Rawlings essentially it's it's
called Hollywood essentially it's clerks
in a weed store and I when I had written
clerks years ago I wrote the role of
Randall to play myself which is why the
character has all the best jokes and
then as we got close to production I
chickened out I was like I'm not a
[ __ ] actor I literally lost
confidence in myself kept enough to go
forward as a director but I was like
you're nobody's [ __ ] actor don't
[ __ ] take the role so I gave the role
to Jeff Anderson and I took Silent Bob
instead so we've only ever made two
clerks movies if I had played Rand I'll
be honest with you we would be on clerks
39 right now so it's probably good that
I didn't play [ __ ] Randall but
there's always been a part of me I was
like oh man like I wish I had taken the
role of the other guy like the guy that
got to talk and stuff like that
instead I acted without words for years
so when we did Holly weed I got to kind
of do that it was like kind of making
clerks in the weed store felt fun I was
like oh [ __ ] you closed a circle you did
play the other guy like you wanted to
originally but didn't and stuff we
fremantle to get out into the world no
buyers whatsoever like so many pilots in
this town and it just sat on my computer
desktop for forever and periodically I'd
wake up in the morning if I wasn't
writing something I'd blaze and I'd
watch Halle weed and be like [ __ ] this
would have been fun man I wish we could
have kept going I would say to Jourdan
Monsanto Jason's wife who runs our
company like hey I one day we should
find a little money and make a little
more like 30 more minutes 40 more
minutes of Halle we'd turn it into like
a feature film that would just bring the
festivals or something because it was
fun to do I had a good time doing it and
stuff just kind of lived in the
background and was something that was
never gonna happen again there's a
company called rivet tv.com came forward
and said they have this platform that
they've built for introducing shows that
didn't go anywhere essentially taking a
pilot give it a one more shot at life by
throwing it to the audience and being
like do you like this if so a buck 99 to
99 you could pre buy the [ __ ] show
and we'll make them and stuff like that
so I was like oh my god I have a [ __ ]
show that nobody ever [ __ ] saw please
take a look at it rivet TV looked at
Halle weed and they took it so we shot a
new ending
or just to give it some [ __ ] closure
and it goes online tomorrow absolutely
[ __ ] free you can watch it everyone
shares dope on the Facebook page on like
YouTube anywhere on their platform as
well and then if you like it and you're
like I want to see more then you could
choose to like finance it and then we
make I think six more something like
that if not you're like I watched some
[ __ ] for free and then go on with your
life but I think it's it's one of those
things where like sometime we were
talking before about getting [ __ ]
stuck with with block writer's block
instead you know sometimes life throws
in a [ __ ] block it ain't even used
sometimes you're like [ __ ] we took it
all the way and there's nowhere left to
take it and stuff but hold on because
this business changes every day now
technology is changing it constantly so
much so that like years ago something
was dead it was dead there's no second
chance of life and now all of a sudden
like this thing may come back to life
because of Technology because there's a
platform because they can put you a
creator in direct touch with the
audience in a way that like no other
creative elements have been able to do
prior to this so tomorrow it goes live
you'll be able to watch anywhere online
for free it's about twenty five twenty
seven minutes twenty six probably
donnell rawlings is fantastic and it
Adam Brody's in it he's fantastic in it
Frankie Shaw who's on Showtime smilk
she's in it she's fantastic Jason Mewes
is in it he's all right yeah Ralph
Garman is it's it's a good [ __ ] time
man so if you're got 30 minutes for you
tomorrow pop by watch it online if you
like it maybe throw down a few bucks and
we get to make a few more thank you for
your patience
Meister all the story never [ __ ] give
up ever ever if you believe in it and
you think it's fun just keep swimming
you can I've said it before it I'll say
it many times like you if you're patient
and you're diligent you can have and get
everything that you dream about in this
life the problem is you won't ever get
it on your schedule mm-hmm and you won't
ever [ __ ] get it the way you think
it's going to happen but as long as you
leave yourself open for it man as long
as you're not waiting you don't have a
schedule for a success or conclusion or
something there's always as long as
you're above ground there's always time
to like [ __ ] close that circle and so
I look I don't know if Holly week goes
on the idea of it is like you need
enough people to support it for it to
keep going but here it is with a
potential shot at [ __ ] life and stuff
take the shot
it's always [ __ ] worth taking when
they said to me like would you be
interested in doing this I was like are
you kidding me I [ __ ] dream about
people [ __ ] seeing this one day
because I acted with words so now people
are gonna [ __ ] it see it and and so if
you're Harbor and something you got
something where you're like [ __ ] man
like I thought I was right about it
you are right just give it time give it
[ __ ] patience man it may come around
you'll never know ladies and gentlemen
of the scum and villainy Cantina have
you got a good time this evening give it
up for an amazing guest give it up for
Jay lazy Luke Cage season shows on
Netflix right now Creed 2 is coming out
very soon the man to my left is the guy
without whom we have no well we'd have a
fat man a Batman but be so stupid with
no good thoughts in it give it up for
Mark Barnard and Lady
and that is fat man on Batman for this
week I'm Kevin Smith I am mark barnard
I'm Jo terekhova tune in next time same
bat-time same bat-channel SModcast comm
or youtube.com slash Kevin's from the
scum and villainy canteen on Hollywood
good night ladies gentlemen
[Applause]
[Music]
you